well obviously we're here to talk about
your newest fragrance and the thing for
me so I haven't smelled it yet because I
wanted to smell it kind of live with you
guys but my new action live reaction and
the thing my question is always like
because obviously there's four of you
yeah how do you actually manage to agree
on what it's gonna be because you must
have different tastes yeah and me Jane
got quite similar toaster smells
yeah but then I think because the last
one was very much as it must must get
musky is very sophisticated it was very
grown-up smell so we felt like for this
one it we wanted it to be more fun and
quite what's the word not fruity and
fruity and more summery mmm
I'm intrigued yeah it is definitely
lighter isn't it yeah but the other one
was a lot more was more mature I would
say this sounds more fun more summery
but do you literally go okay this did
you bring kind of like fragrances you
like and go okay this I want it to be a
bit more like that yeah oh my god yeah
yeah least of all eight different tones
like will smell like vanilla e smells
and fruity smells and they like become
you combine this and take that out make
its it's a really long process until you
like finally get like what you think is
opposed yeah and when you guys perform
do you wear fragrance or not I talk
about those things obviously you're like
that like you guys are energetic you're
dancing I wanna have you wear fragrance
or do I don't know perform we don't
really but we go out and night out I
think it's really important to be smell
nice and you meet an increase in people
I think that when people like go through
the day and they give you a cuddle or a
kiss and the cheating and the like who
are you wearing they are like one people
yeah
well when you get in like a taxi or
something in the test-drive yeah you
smell wolf wear thank you so much thank
you mine yeah and that's very good and
also I would cuz I was noticing some see
you guys love makeup and we love makeup
a glamour I mean we're like makeup
obsessed and I like when I walked in I
was like oh I'm feeling like left out so
you guys all kind of matched uh the
range and fragrance and growing up has
fragrance always been something
that you know you guys were into or do
or is it something that kind of you got
into as you got older or was this like
to remember your first kind of fragrance
yeah yeah you always remember like even
from like being like five when you spell
your mom's perfume and you're like to
sit in a dressing table trying to like
be here
um yeah like from a very young age is
you get used to lights that's smelling
perfumes and stuff and then when you get
a leg comprehensive school you finally
get your first poo yeah yeah and what I
love as well different performs reminder
of different parts of your life mmm like
or different holidays yeah yeah yeah
holiday perfume don't you yeah so like
they would remind you of different
things do is they're like what do you
remember what like your first one was or
kind of what something that compelled
you think mine was don't [ __ ] about a
light blue all night
I still use that yes that's great that
and then I loved the Britney Britney
spring oh yeah I love from everyone has
that curious is quite good as well and
paint the lingerie was fantasy wasn't it
yeah yeah loved gems in it but everybody
knew that perfume didn't they yeah you
smell you know what that was they still
do really well yeah anyway yeah another
one but anyway we're hurt not here to
talk about you guys um so I do want to
go back to to the makeup because like I
said I camera you know we are obsessed
and I'm kind of you know pretty obsessed
with your looks I remember I don't know
if you remember when you came to the
glamour Awards this year I was one of
the people who interviewed you on the
record I remember and I was like you
guys look like I was literally you I
love the fact that you're not ashamed
the fact that you love makeup do you
mean like sorry and and I feel like when
you guys do with your looks you really
kind of think about it as individuals as
well so I know today obviously we're
matching but I want to ask you when you
first started out did you was it um did
you go more for a uniform look and then
you work towards your personalities more
or do you always feel you matched more
your own person no we always from the
very beginning we've always gone with
what we feel comfortable with and also
we've got we've got different color skin
tones even got a hair so what's may suit
me would never suit peri
so know we're very individual we'd like
to keep it that way I think that's what
in a way brings us to get far I like the
yellow different
is cool yeah like even our lips today
even though we've won for the poor to
you yeah lightly but also different like
there's more matte or shiny yeah I mean
I kind of love that that you have
personality and you're not just like
kind of copy know like oh we're all the
same okay we all have to you know um but
are there any looks when you look back
that that you think could never ever in
my life go I want to know this again but
give me an example girls except yeah I
you would be eyelashes with like bobbles
and the little actuaries we just got a
flung on our face so we didn't have a
choice we didn't want to say things I
didn't want to be divas but I've never
heard anyone say you guys are diva no I
feel like I feel like if we we did then
everyone would be like Oh what do you
kind of sense teachers would yeah and we
also we went from wearing hardly
anything I didn't know about McCarthy
dolled up some just having a full face
like every year yeah you really so we
have to get used to that
but obviously now like we've evolved we
know what suits us we know what we love
in our face we're not that makes us look
good
yes so we've had Adam Burrell our makeup
artist from like day one yeah I've kind
of grown to kind of learn a lot about
makeup
you like stole my next question and then
you just made I was going to ask you
because you know you've been very
straight faithful to Adam as you know
you makeup artist so can you each one of
you tell me what's one thing he taught
you about your own you know the way you
do your makeup that that you've kind of
like you know adopt like learned from
him the main thing and for me and I've
got like quite chubby cheeks so I think
contour is like my go-to like it's so
important for me what's the thing
whatever secret is no sometimes I think
I look at you and your contour T and I
know it's makeup because we're being
filmed but it's natural you don't have
stripe design what is the secret like
specially yeah you that you'd use cream
or powder alright we have to have
details oh yeah I would yeah we don't
use powder and obviously like you know
you get those like shaped brushes are
just specifically for contour that is
smaller they make easier to go on yeah
and you can get it like really good on
and and yeah not no lines nothing too
heavy it has to be
natural looking so yeah god I'd probably
say contour and never used to work on
talk so I was just to think I'm scared
of it probably yeah
contour and right the right eyelashes
for your eyes for the shape of your I
think is always good like when we were
on x-factor we literally got given most
horrendous eyelashes to wear and they
literally really like we had no eyeballs
it was just a laugh oh it's just so hard
to like I don't even know how to do it
myself like today I'm doing it yourself
yet when you put the glue on leave it
for a bit don't put you straight on your
is always gonna slip off let go a little
bit tacky sometimes I fit you guys one
bit when you've got a little bit of
mascara on your eye and then put it on
and then always seal it with a little
bit of black liner yes as at the top of
it so you've got no blue showing and
it's also practice as well because I
have no idea how to put lashes on yeah
that's always easy as well if you do it
with tweezers put them on with tweezers
trying to put it with your fingers is
hard I mean somebody I find it's easier
to stick them down really just becomes
an opinion I'm useless I'm but I'm
useless but I find that that's a tip I
think yeah yeah not everyone has
problems to them sticking yeah you need
to let it tak good luck go tacky yeah
then it will stick perfectly what about
you Jay oh I sorry and probably like
what brushes and things to use cuz at
the beginning when that another sphere
foundation anyways but as always he's
know that like block flat brush and I'm
just like kicker only I was doing a pin
and whereas I I've learned like over the
years what a delight what brushes to use
like it doesn't have to be kicked on
this and watching and especially is
well-liked because we've all been
different hair colors learning like what
kind of lips colors and stuff suit what
hair colors my eyeshadows they always
learn it like compliment you're here
with you outfit and you everything else
that's going on so yeah
everything yeah and like yeah everything
um your things your brows are yeah
honestly I think contour as well I think
eyelashes especially for me because I
love the round I look I love eyelashes
that are shorter either end and longer
in the middle to create like a really
wide eye and then when I have a flick I
have one cycle shorter and then longer
out to I mean yes like more very good
makeup artist like Oh only cause of Adam
we volunteered but I think as well as
blendin like yeah what you do like I
shadow if you put eyeshadow on and you
think you've got it wrong to blend it in
it it goes back joining like I think
it's just practice and experiment in a
bit as well and like lip liners and
never you know what lip liner what's my
lip liners it would be like you see I
Bobby gloss and a clear mascara yeah and
now I'm like oh I want it all like yeah
but it's all about blending blending
everything in so or looks natural and
not too and which one of you do you
think is the best I'll actually doing
makeup Jade oh you all hate g'day she's
my eyes she has her makeup done I'm not
oh I didn't saw your makeup no she's I
did it me said she's your good and do
you have to do the other girls know oh
yeah last tour not the one just gone the
tour forged in my makeup I love tits
gradually get love to yes right eyes
like if you go on my flat like it's just
images got to Simon sweet or you bike
I'm gonna love that
I'm literally addicted like eyeshadow
palettes and I don't even use half as a
look
miron just you know and then you watch
all those I mean you guys ever watched
makeup tutorials on YouTube oh the
taichiwu I never share Peter yeah is a
month a standstill I say my people say
on it you only wear me go for like what
was that people are for a boy or
something oh no I just love Nichol oh
it's a nice max table yeah crap we spent
like we can go to America to Australia
to like wherever in the world we are
more Gorda Michael will be enough hours
oh my god you're gonna learn more girls
like happen and finally I do have to
ask you this because you know who would
be like is there one person that's
always been your beauty icon that you
kind of always think oh like me for
example I'm obsessed with JLo at all
times I don't look anything like her but
I want to look like her or anyone that
you kind of look up and I'm always like
Oh for me he's Kim Chi yeah all the way
all of them the whole family mmm just
Laura Lee that's like it's just the most
beautiful makeup it's ridiculous
um i publicize ndr yeah she's insane I
thought she does her own makeup as well
didn't she she's so good
no way yes she does her own makeup oh my
gosh my eye on that picture perfectly bs
I'm gonna be hard
and obviously Rihanna as well oh she's
gray cut I really like the three
provinces and makeup she always gets at
the right balance of a not looking to
kicked she does a really good flicked
eyeliner that I tried a copy and I liked
her face look at eyeliner today yes I'm
flying away yeah it's a bigan ah alright
you Perry I don't really have anyone I I
don't think this anyone you obviously
obviously you okay I don't excite anyone
I sit in like straw and strong for me
it's a nice donkey yeah Twiggy's amazing
but you can't really get away with that
whole drawn on bottom eyelash thing
every day I think you could with your
eyes you've got those beautiful eyes
thank you you absolutely hood that's
remanded I that's such a good tip yeah
but no nobody like makeup wise that I
can think of thank you so much for the
chat was that are you telling like your
tip something that's not mine thank you
you're gonna love for more little make
subscribe to glamour
down here